[Music]
all right everybody good like i know
what y'all just went through i did it a
few weeks ago i feel like i know it was
a lot it was tense he put you through it
we're gonna talk about it um robert i
have to start with the fact that you
love to take what i would say like bible
entries something that you saw where
you're like this is a guiding force so
what did you see on that trip to iceland
that made it into the film from that
first time you started to think about it
well
yeah i didn't i was never interested in
in vikings the the like i can't believe
i made such a macho movie because
the macho stuff just really put me off
and then
as a kid and then as an adult the
right-wing nazi misappropriation of
viking culture kind of totally turned me
off but then
iceland
yeah the the landscapes they're just the
they were like so aw inspiring and
ancient and and brutal
uh and
you know they made me
wanna pick up some of the icelandic
sagas and and and learn about this this
culture uh but
the
landscapes were so elemental and and and
you know what kind of stayed from that
first trip was i was thinking when we
were driving around
uh about
maybe i could make a viking movie and i
think it should end with a naked sword
fight on a volcano
i just love that so much i mean um
listen um i love the incredible i think
ideas that spring from you forth from
your imagination that we get to witness
whether it is a
sort of you know shire you know the the
crucible tail with imagery of religion
or we're taking we're talking about you
know seductive mermaids and then a
remote lighthouse but i do have to say
when you're gonna do a sex scene with
that kind of landscapes i'm not going to
say it was a poor choice but
where was that shot i just have to talk
about that shot because it was one of
the ones that i'm like yeah there's a
lot going on down here with with anya
and alexander but it's gorgeous and i
just want to talk about that and some of
the other places you chose as far as
those locations well one of the
yeah
so we were a week before we were going
to go to camera and then we went into
lockdown
and uh
and
that hiatus gave us a lot more time to
plan and and and uh
actors to grow their beards longer and
sets to gestate and grow into the
landscapes but one of the problems with
kovid was that we couldn't shoot very
much in iceland we
we had we had to shoot all of principal
photography in
northern ireland and then i was like
well we're running out of places that
look like iceland so then we were also
allowed to shoot in regular ireland and
that
location was shot in a place called
glenith horseshoe
and we you know built our own
icelandic hot tub into the landscape
um and uh yeah but then the very
following scene was shot in ice actually
in iceland uh like
nearly a year
later uh but
i was very glad that it was gloomy
when we were shooting that scene at glen
of horseshoe because if they were like
making out in the hot tub with the
horses making out in the background and
then the waterfall and it had been like
uh beauty it would have just been like
really cheesy it would have been too
much of a romance novel come to life but
just as a romance novel reader i didn't
mind that so i'll just say um on top of
all the blood and the death and all the
gore that you put us through it's a nice
little juxtaposition i will say
the person that was wielding so much of
that mayhem as we saw from just the
original almost opening shot was
alexander and what you sort of put him
through on this um talk about him
signing on to this because i know
he more than anything really pushed you
for not just authenticity but the idea
of this is what viking culture needed it
needed a grand epic that could really
show the culture well he so so okay so i
went to iceland
naked sword to find out a volcano and i
didn't give
a viking movie a whole lot of thought uh
for two years
until i had lunch with alexander
skarsgard who said that he who now he'd
loved vikings since he was a kid and and
he'd been and and he told me he'd been
trying for 10 years to make a viking
movie and he didn't have a script that
he really liked and i said i i've got a
viking story i just had the naked sword
fight but uh
but then uh we kind of shook hands and
said let's let's try to make it work so
uh but but he but we talked about the
sagas and we talked about you talked
about
liking the witch and my approach to
you know doing things historically
accurate uh um so i don't know that
sentence made sense but in any case um
yeah so so so yeah ask me another
question because i'm failing here no
you're not here i definitely want to
give you a chance to talk about how
during the shooting that sort of mission
of alexander's was was ever present just
because he was such sort of i guess
an encyclopedia of knowledge for it he
was keeping you honest i guess was part
what you said
yeah i think that it was really just
that like he did he he demanded
perfection of
the film and of himself but i think that
like as far as
uh
viking
nerd
like
competition like uh you know i win
the that contest you win the contest but
i like that i like that but yeah i mean
we were so lucky because we were we were
bringing on you know the finest like
historians and archaeologists like in
in in the field of viking studies uh to
to help tell the story i do love that
did you all ever have like a viking
trivia contest on set please tell me how
did that that would have been fun uh
no no come on
maybe you can host one and then then we
can get it yeah they're having a moment
um one of the things i feel the reason
why viking culture is having a moment
and why so many stories i think more on
the small screen but obviously this is
is taking it to another level on the big
screen is
people want to get immersed within the
culture and there's something about
how the culture invites you to sort of
become an avatar within it and this film
very much feels like that just with the
journeys and the shots so i want to talk
to you about your shot selection because
i do feel
within every choice where there's such a
long sequence put together there's a
clear cinematic reasoning behind it but
i also feel like those were such
deliberate choices what was the sort of
impetus to it was each one just that's
where the camera wanted you to be or did
you want this to have more of a longing
shot approach
i think i mean in some ways this is just
like the
the the next step uh after
the witch in the lighthouse and with
what me and my dp jeremy were kind of
trying to do and because uh this is uh
it endeavors to be a more entertaining
movie and a better paced movie uh and an
action movie uh you know the camera is
always moving um but you know um
uh i think i think part of it is a as is
a reaction to the fact that action
movies like this often are
m are almost always shot multiple camera
and uh and you know when kurosawa shot
his historical epics multiple camera it
was done with a lot of craft and
specificity and a lot of times now it's
it's done without a lot of craft and
specificity
and it's not like you know there's
hasn't been any single camera
long take action movies in the past 10
years but
it's only like once every couple years
that there's a 1917 or a revenant or
whatever that tries to do this because
it is not easy to do you know it takes a
lot of discipline uh and uh and if but
and it focuses everybody and i mean one
of the things that's great about it is
that like the the entire crew every
single
every every crew member every actor like
you really feel like you are just part
of this
beast you know you're you're you're
you're you're you're a limb you know and
so uh but
so that's fun in the making of it uh but
what it hopefully does for an audience
is that like
uh you're more immersed in in the world
when you're experiencing things
live time you know the the the battle
sequence is not
quote i mean it is a lie because like no
one's dying but it it but you're seeing
each beat play out in lifetime and you
know and and
and i think that that like you know can
be
or endeavors to be you know uh better
more immersive
storytelling for something like this
i mean it definitely the immersive part
of it is it goes without saying the
other thing i think that aids in it and
it was the thing that i remarked when i
sat back here tonight is the sound of it
just how
i would say visceral the hits feel and
just how gory the moments are and i know
that that is a dance with the sound
mixing so i'll give you this opportunity
to brag on those guys because i know
that they have to almost invent certain
sounds for for this kind of cinema yeah
and i and and especially you know if you
have um
a shot where you're looking at one
central thing but then there's certain
things going on on the sides like
sometimes
you know you know you need to hear those
things in order to see them you know so
so it was it was a tricky it was a
tricky mix and it i mean and it took a
lot of work and
uh you know and the sound team was
amazing but the other thing that we were
really trying to do particularly like in
the raid and the post raid is is
the
voice performers who do crowd stuff have
a lot of technique
you know and they're like
you know and they just do it and you
know and we would have to say like like
okay
like we got to feel this pain like you
have to you like like like you can't
just show up today and scream like you
have to like get into the mindset of
like your husband's just been killed
in front of your eyes and and and and
like and act
you know um
and and that you know and so you know
another way in which we're trying to be
demanding to because the other because
you know the thing is
it's a difficult line to walk where like
this is a big action set-piece tentpole
movie and and it's based on icelandic
sagas that read sometimes like 80s
action movies and so the violence needs
to be thrilling and entertaining at
points but also like i'm not trying to
glorify violence i don't condone
violence so sometimes that brutality
uh
that extra brutality it's not
spectacle it's like
meant to be horrific and
like repellent you know
i think that's the the main concept of
the film that i found to be so
interesting and you see it in the so in
the final moments um after um he's
killed
his mother and you know half brother and
he realizes the monster in this moment
that he's basically become in the quest
of his vengeance and filner comes in
there and he just stares at him and he
just looks
that look is is so shakespearean and
setting up that scene i could see how
some people don't see
what it really does for both of those
characters but in so many ways with the
filner character in particular it just
set up that last battle so
so incredibly i just yeah talk about
when you made that decision in the
scripting and because i think if you
start with the naked sword fight the
question is how do you get there how do
you get there yeah
i mean uh
well thanks for saying so it's really
nice
i think
one of the things that i just loved
about the sagas is
even though
uh
they're
thinking and behaving in ways that is
not modern there's a modernity in in in
the writing in that
you know these people were not are not
black and white
and many of the saga heroes who their
sagas are named after them are outlaws
and uh or like psychopaths and and you
know
and and do
bad things and are conflicted and then
and and the villain might be a loving
husband and like a good father and that
was really interesting to me especially
because in a film of this size like
gener generally like
like you know commodus or the the king
of england and braveheart i mean those
guys are just
bastards like you know and and but
fjallner
is complicated and even even
you know as merciless as he is to kill
his brother
there's you can see he has doubt
in that scene which which which i like
in classes performance and if you're
gonna get nicole kidman to give us a
little mini lady macbeth that's not a
bad thing yeah i mean let's be honest no
and and you know obviously that i mean
that's like
maybe the scene that i'm the most proud
of yeah i was going to use that to tee
up um we haven't even talked about it
yet which is just incredible that we
they have so much to talk about because
this cast alone is a movie for most
people like they don't need anything
else just with this cast and what
they're able to do it's it's a gift
but assembling what you did with folks
from previous work to now
what was that sort of process like was
everybody
in mind
immediately for the role because i know
especially with bringing like anya back
that i obviously think was very specific
you knew that you wanted her for
something
yeah i mean the the roles uh anya and
willem's roles were written
for them um you know no one else can
play
uh a court jester slash shaman aside
from dafoe
and uh you know and thankfully
uh for anya
uh while the viking age was not in great
age to be a woman it was a better age to
be a witch than uh puritan new england
uh so
um
and uh yeah and then you know nicole
uh
thankfully said yes like within 90
seconds of talking to her um you know
she was a fan of the lighthouse and she
said this script had teeth
uh and she's also you know she has a
good relationship with alex
um
you know uh ethan
i'd seen him do
a lot of stage work in shakespeare and
we were really excited when we first
talked that we we were like we're like
look we both know that this is in your
wheelhouse but audiences are going to be
surprised that you are going to be
like
an awesome viking king from the moment
we first
lay eyes on you you know
um
yeah and then of course i'm supremely
lucky that the bjerk was in the movie
um but that again it's it that comes
down to kind of relationships too
because robin carolyn
one of the composers you know he'd
worked with bjerk so he introduced me
and my wife to bjerk she introduced me
to shown the co-writer
they'd known each other since they were
teenagers it was a familial atmosphere
so so bjerk was down
i really do love the fact that because i
mean like i do feel like there's just a
very short list of like if you want to
just automatically make this be like
this is the icelanders movie they're
gonna love it bjork is obviously the one
and so i'm that was and then just her
playing the seer and like behind all
that makeup the poster for her is simply
incredible um it brings to the whole
idea
it's this film it's shakespearean it's
also has a lot of religious imagery and
you know everything from the crone to
the seer to the jesters to
you know mothers maidens and witches
again i just have to think this is
something that really intrigues you and
so i'm curious
if there's any particular icelandic
tales that maybe didn't explicitly get
put in this but that you definitely
would sort of want to point folks to
from some of the imagery
um
yeah i was talking about like
in the last q and a i did today
arabia saga which is a good one to check
out with a lot of
uh
rituals and magic but that has uh ghost
seals
uh which we didn't get an opportunity to
have in in the film was that in the
script at one point no no
i was like let me tell you but yeah i
mean um
i mean the the first the first version
that of the script that shown finished
would have been like a 250 million
dollar movie there was so much stuff in
it uh some something that that was in a
lot of sagas is
like instead of cock fighting like horse
fighting
uh which would have been very expensive
uh
and yeah get up for those horses that's
what they would have been yeah cgi but i
mean either way they've got to get up
there and like you know stage out here
we're already shooting the horse
fighting for your next film uh no we're
not gonna do that i i do have to say too
with um
with the entire cast and what everybody
did with it i feel like whenever you
sort of write something whether you're
doing it um with the idea of somebody in
mind or what the actor does with it
there's always a surprising moment where
an actor takes something that you wrote
into a different direction that you
found
you know just again surprising and great
and i'm just curious if you could share
one of those from this experience i
think um
this movie more than any of my other
films was has been a bit of
plan and execute
but i think um
in in the lighthouse robert pattinson
surprised me
and surprised dafoe and surprised
himself like all the time and a lot of
times rob did things and that are in the
finished film they're very different
from
how i had imagined them
and it's amazing
defoe did everything exactly how i
imagined it
that doesn't make it any worse
that's right you know what i'm saying
yeah no very true
no i love that um i want to check really
quickly because i want to make sure i
didn't bring my clock up i want to make
sure we're good on time whoever my time
person is i can't see them hopefully
okay well they'll tell me um i think
we're still good on time but again i'm
looking for my little light and i didn't
see it so uh i'm gonna go ahead and
bring it to to this one um to with
whatever you're thinking of doing next
because the one thing i will say with
the northman is
as i said you know he's three for three
ladies and gentlemen should see that
certified fresh symbol pretty soon for
for this one as well and
from your first film to this one i've
just been such a fan of your work
is there a specific thing because you
look at the film you can see some themes
where religion
crows very big very big all the way
through each one
when you're looking for your next
project and where you maybe want to tell
stories less is is it
is it just finding the right trip or are
there specific areas that you find to be
essential to the type of cinema that you
want to make because
again it's very rare that a director can
have such a clear signature this early
on and it's kind of remarkable that it's
such at a high level
well uh thanks and impressively so so
thank you it's very kind uh you well
okay the first but the most important
thing is that i need a title that starts
with uh
um
but i mean
look i'm always i'm always you know it's
it's uh history religion mythology
uh
folktales fairy tales the occult i mean
that's
that's what i'm into you know and i it's
not
likely to change anytime soon so
hopefully people don't get sick of it
well i mean look at this though but you
went in a totally different direction
with this by making it such i said to
someone when i first saw it
this is his most approachable i would
say endeavor and that's incredible
but i think i was like if people are
going to look for his other work i just
want to tell them it gets weird so this
is the first film that they see
but
i would say like let me see that version
of the musical let me see that version
of
you know a family drama like you know
like there's a lot of that in this one
too so yeah what would be sort of like
the strange combination to add to those
themes like you did with this one with
big action
yeah i mean i think the
the the only thing
uh maybe minorly surprising that i would
be interested in doing is is science
fiction
excellent which is not likely to be next
but
why'd you just disappoint everyone in
this room well
i'm just kidding no it's great it's not
likely to be next so does that mean you
know exactly what's next
i will
uh
be
as uncooperative and elusive as possible
if
respectfully oh he definitely knows all
right well
i want to thank you so much for this
this is a great chat i want to thank all
of you for watching and i want to thank
film independent for hosting youtube
thank you
thanks for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
you